ich meine freunde und herzlich
willkommen von sylt wir sind heute hier
weil es ist derzeit der world cup sylt
ist nämlich der weltweit grösste wir
sind hier weil wir eingeladen wurden vom
vodafone dafür verwendet ihr vielleicht
und schnell
es ist schon ein bisschen später das ist
gerade schon 16 uhr weil wir wollen die
ganze zeit im livestream ideen waren
beispielsweise im somit boden gefahren
sind
da hab ich aber tatsächlich was gefilmt
es war recht anstrengend zu filmen
zeigen oder was ich geschafft habe
hier gerade wo wir sind ist das
fahrerlager hier über formel 1 und alle
fahren wollen den live stream um so ein
bisschen da zum sommer sachen zu
entdecken und alles hier erklärt was
surfen angeht im zdf magst du nicht
haben ja auch aber das haben wir vor
1000 jahren wahr gemacht wollte jetzt
wieder mal von uns
bitte einfach nein nein schreibt einfach
dass das rennen da hinten in vollem
gange ist das heißt sie können euch
einfach mal direkte bilder von finden
hob stück gelaufen da hingefahren gerade
alle die etwas älter
die teilweise keine august in km h das
ist verdammt schnell
genau dort komplett aus wasserkraft ganz
offen
hier scheinen segelt red
wir laufen jetzt noch ein bisschen rum
und ich zeige euch was ihr sonst noch so
entdecken
vodafone macht halt hier insbesondere
diese live stream halt auch das heißt
wenn ihr denkt war geil surfen ist
legendär beschreibung da könnt ihr euch
den live stream anschauen
nein ich kriege nicht 40 millionen euro
auf ein konto überwiesen dafür dass ich
das sage sondern es ist halt einfach so
die arbeit diesen live stream und die
haben uns eingeladen und wir dürfen hier
sein und das genießen den regen
scheiße
ja ja ja wir gehen muss trocknen
liga
die kann fliegen ich glaub an mich und
landschaft 1 exchange bekommt
was dort freunde
pd
sollte bender disease control act man
nicht direkt wegfliegen kommt ihr
wahrscheinlich schon auf einem bild
gesehen habe was ich bei instagram
hochgeladen habe sind wir halt speedport
gefahren aber ich euch sehen am anfang
schon eingeblendet allerdings sind dabei
meine schuhe so ein bisschen nass
geworden und jetzt laufen wir grad
halten barfuß herum wieder besser
deswegen gehen jetzt gerade die
innenstadt und schauen ob wir vielleicht
irgendwo ein paar latschen finden paar
crocs irgendwas niemals crocs wir müssen
auf jeden fall hin was anderen wenn wir
am flughafen sind flieger sitzen und
schuhwerk ich habe schuhe gefunden aber
die gleichen die ich vorher auch hatte
nur in größer und ich merke jetzt schon
ziemlich irgendwie viel zu groß sind
solche zugegeben wir entdecken grad neue
wege die noch nie jemand auf
zurückgegangen ich hier ich gerade kein
mensch
wir gehen jetzt auf jeden fall zurück an
den strand und schauen was es da noch so
alles zu entdecken gibt
wir wollen das war es jetzt hier mit
diesem video vom zelt wo wir echt kalt
ich hoffe ich habe das ein bisschen
gefallen ich habe versucht einfach ein
paar eindrücke von mir von dem tag hier
den ich bin max hier verbringen durfte
zu sammeln so ein bisschen zu schauen
die fahren dahin tatsächlich immer noch
nett aber dahin sind die immer noch
empfangen da sieht man den ganzen tag
schon jedenfalls war es das jetzt hier
vom blog ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen
war geil eigentlich oder sind das wetter
war wirklich so ein bisschen regnerisch
ein bisschen bewölkt und es war gerade
als speed boot gefahren waren mega kalt
und auch mit regen und so zwar nicht so
cool aber es war ein mega cool erfahrung
dass pete bootfahren waren einfach cool
zu sehen wie es am weltcup im surfen
abläuft und zwar geht er nicht nur heute
sondern geht noch sechs weitere tage
meint oder sogar noch neun watt oder
noch acht jeden fall geht er noch ein
bisschen so eine woche ca ihr findet den
link und in der beschreibung wo er
einfach bei einem live stream zu schauen
können oder wo ihr eventuell auch noch
mal anschauen könnt was wir da gemacht
haben das wohl gespeichert
speicherkarten fusel aus meiner guard
gekauften jogginghose verloren das war
es auf jeden fall jetzt von bild und ich
sehe euch jetzt am flughafen dem
flugzeug wieder